بعد اكثر من 20 يوم هنا في شمال قطاع غزه
تمكنت طواقم الدفاع المدني من انتشال
عشرات الشهداء ممن كانوا تحت ركام المنازل
وايضا ممن كانوا في الطرقات وفي الشوارع
لم تتمكن خلال الفتره السابقه الطواقم من
الوصول لهؤلاء الشهداء بسبب مركز قوات
الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال في هذه المناطق
طبعا مازال هناك عشرات الشهداء لم تتمكن
الطواقم من الوصول لهم في اماكن كثيره هنا
في شمال القطاع طبعا عدد كبير من هذه
الجثامين تحللت هنا في الطرقات وفي
الشوارع وتحت ركام
المنازل اغلبهم ايضا مجهولو الهويه لم يتم
التعرف
عليهم الان
الطواقم حاول دفنهم هنا في احد الاراضي في
هذه
[موسيقى]
المنطقه في هذا اليوم تمكنا الحمد لله من
انتشال العشرات من الشهداء ويتم دفنهم
الان في مقبره جماعيه بجوار المستشفى
الاندونيسي وبمساعده طواقمنا طبعا كما
تعلمون ن نعمل بدون اي امكانيات او اي
اليات للاسف الشديد لن لم نتمكن الوصول
اليه
الاحتلال لا يزال متواجدا على اطراف
المنطقه ووجدنا صعوبه كبيره جدا في الدخول
الى المكان
والطرقات المنازل المحطمه والملقا في
الشوارع ايضا الشوارع غير غير امنه للحركه
فيها لا يزال الاحتلال يستهدف الكثير من
من الماره ويستهدف الطواقم
ايضا مقبره جماعيه لعشرات الشهداء لم يتم
التعرف عليهم وما زال هناك كبير في
الطرقات وفي الشوارع انس الشريف الجزيره
شمال غزه